everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're in the
final day of the 2017 champions showdown
there's only two competitors left magnus
carlsen the world champion in england
the Chinese Grand Master who will be
playing in the candidates tournament
next year trying to get a chance to play
Magnus Carlsen for the world
championship all the other competitors
they started earlier so they finished
early but we just have a heads-up battle
between Magnus Carlsen and ding Larian
and the world champion Carlson has
pretty much dominated for the past three
days and today they're gonna be playing
12 games of blitz chess with five-minute
time controls they get no extra time
added for each additional move so the
game will last no more than 10 minutes
in total each sides getting five minutes
why it's gonna be played in this game by
Deng Lin and blacks gonna be played by
Magnus Carlsen we'll go ahead and get
started the knight to f3 and that f6
pawn c4 pawn c5 so getting into the
English opening symmetrical opening
Knight to c3 pawn East six pawn g3 we've
seen some crazy different openings from
these two players specifically that we
haven't really seen from the other six
competitors that we're here or a
top-level play but they you can tell
they studied up for this particular
tournament with the blitz and the rapid
section knowing that their opponents
would not be as prepared for these
faster variations of chess and so just
trying out some new stuff Bishop here to
g2 being kiddo on the kingside Bishop b7
both sides really trying to control the
light squares and the board castle on
the kingside upon a6 rook e1
centralizing and then we see after
Pawnee for exchange in the center of the
board and this is a hedgehog pawn
formation you don't see it all that
often from blacks perspective he trades
off his C pawn for his opponents D pawn
it many times white will have a pawn
here on c4 in e4 but black has pawn
structure on a 6b 6d six six headshot
formation I just don't see it too often
at high level play many times it looks
like it's cramped from blacks
perspective but there's so many ways
I can counter depending on where white
wants to go that many players tend to
like this sort of play because they can
go down some very aggressive paths if
they want to and they can adjust if they
wanted to play a Knight to d7 and then
come down here to c5 they could play
that if they wanted to control the dark
squares or the light squares in the turn
of the board they can adjust depending
on where their opponent goes to so this
gives magnus carlsen a lot of options
depending on how the Chinese Grandmaster
wants to continue for white Maddox plays
Queen to c7 just continuing his
development Bishop here to e3 same as
well getting the dark squared Bishop
involved into the game Knight to d7 rook
over here to c1 just getting ready to
push forward in the stern of the board
rook to c8 getting the rooks involved to
the semi open file it'll be interesting
to see what magnus carlsen does with his
King here as far as castling on the King
side of the board are not castling on
the king sided board pawn to f4 and this
is where things start to get interesting
from white always if you think you know
it's tough to push one of your pawns
because there's just so much in front of
your King and pushing forward is so much
space that if your opponent can ever
break through can have a huge attack on
your King so from here we just don't see
it too often but from White's
perspective he needs to be pretty
aggressive here and he's down so many
games to Magnus Carlsen he has to throw
everything he can he can't sit back and
let Magnus Carlsen attack him so why I
like this move it is very very difficult
I think in a blitz game to play this
against mantis Carlsen because he is
going to attack relentlessly at your
king now Queen back here to b8 this
opens up for this rook on c8 to attack
and also just defend the semi open file
if he wants to play Knight to c5 at some
point pawn to g4 says okay we're going
all-in right here and I think this is
where Magnus Carlsen decided that he was
not going to castle on the Kings side
usually want to do that for King side
safety and then attack on the Queen side
but it doesn't really look like the
Queen sides where the action is going on
he can easily attack on the kingside his
opponents king is not safe at all he
needs to make sure that he's protected
here and all I think that's gonna happen
is pee castle on the King side is he
waste a move and then his opponent can
continue to throw everything in the
kitchen sink at the king side so for now
decides not to castle plays pawn to h5
and said says yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
pretend and play as though I Castle down
the Queen side and start to throw
everything add to your king side of the
board punt up here to g5 forcing the
Knights move Knight comes down here to
g4 it is has a nice little outpost from
this pawn on h5 also attacking the
bishop here on e3 and then pawn up to g6
so white trying to be extremely
aggressive right here and you know
there's a few options on the board we
see rook takes on c4 if instead after
pawn to g6 we were to see the knight
take on e3 well this gets tricky because
now the rook recaptures and then we
could see pawn to e5 and the pond takes
the king recaptures maybe now this pawn
takes White's really controlling the
center of the board this King is open
ready for attack rook here to c2 getting
ready to swing over here to f2 i think
this puts a lot of unnecessary pressure
on Magnus Carlsen could have also if he
came back here said instead of taking
with my knight here what if I tried just
pawn to f6 well this is just as bad
because then Knight to e6 of blowing up
the center of the board there's now an
isolated pawn here on d6 that y can
start to attack next move Knight to d5
if doesn't really matter you know kind
of what black decides to do here he
needs to hold on to this pawn to maybe
rook to g8 and then Knight to d5 if
there is an exchange great Queen comes
up here takes on d5 White's just
completely winning this middle of the
board state I think this will be a easy
victory for white so in the game Magnus
Carlsen decided yeah I'm not gonna worry
about that pawn too much I'm gonna go
ahead and take material here on c4 after
the pawn takes the King recaptures on f7
so both
have a king exposed now just comes down
to time control who can attack their
opponent quickly and come out with a
victory
why continues with Bishop down here to
f1 attacking the rook and then now the
knight decides to go ahead and take here
on a3 as we expected at some point rook
captures on e3 rook captures here on d4
so decides yeah I want to give up my
rook here this night here on d4 is the
very powerful square so I'm gonna go
ahead and take that Queen recaptures
upon here to be five I why definitely
one this exchange he has a queen two
rooks a bishop and a knight getting into
the endgame black does only have this
one rook over here on h8 and it's not
very active right now you know he had it
here to push forward with the pawn Age 5
but by age 5 initially he was attacking
on the Kings side it's kind of all by
himself right now this Queen on ba de is
kind of stuck right here not doing too
much so you know all things considered I
think white definitely has a advantage
in the spot and even b5 doesn't seem
like it as too much on this board state
maybe if he tried something else d5
trying to block off the center of the
board have some counter pull he has both
the pawn in the bishop defending this
square so I think this gives him some
options and swingers rook over to the
center try to control it a little bit
but pawn to b5 okay sure yeah we'll go
with that a rook to g3 just starting to
attack some pieces he has a queen and a
rook both attacking the square here on
g7 so you can see the threat that's
happening here Bishop to f6 putting a
stop to that and then Ponce it to e5 I'm
not sure that pond e5 is really the best
play here it's really just stopping your
queen from attacking this diagonal right
here could have maybe tried Queen back
here to III not push forward right away
but in the game decided to play pawn to
e5 Bishop comes back here to d8 and then
the decisive move in the game and that
is the knight
coming here to e4 unfortunately white
didn't see that after Bishop back here
to d8 this was not necessarily fully a
retreat move sometimes you always want
to have multiple things going on with
your moves in this particular case the
pawn comes up here to e5 Dingley and I
think just thought yeah the bishop has
to move back here so he comes back today
didn't see where it could come to and
that is after Knight to e4 then Bishop
down to b6 pinning the Queen to the King
here on a g1 White's gonna go down a ton
of material now you can look at it and
you could say there's definitely ways to
block this if white just wants to give
up free material it's a knight to c5
okay that's fine then I can come here
freely take the night here on c5 the
Queen still has to move it gets kind of
awkward because Knight to a4 that's
still defending the bishop the queen is
being pinned down so the Queen's gonna
have to move more than likely you know
could throw his rook up here to c5
White's just gonna go down too much
material and and all in all I think Dean
Lane has just been emotionally dominated
over this series and well I think he
probably would have lost I would have
liked to seen him play a little bit
longer but resigned after he saw the
move Bishop here to b6 and just for
those kind of looking at the entire
tournament Magnus Carlsen to just kind
of explain how dominant he was they play
30 games and these are Blitzen rapid and
if you see high-level play there's
there's not as many wins as you would
expect but Magnus Carlsen over the 30
games he won 16 games and he lost two
and then he tied the remaining 12th one
16 and lost - so just absolutely
dominated and I think that's part of
what just led to this Dean Larian was
like okay yeah this isn't gonna go well
I've been playing for three days this
guy's just been destroying me I don't
want to play any longer let's go and
pack up go to the next game get these
five
minute blitz games out of the way so I
can go home because I just don't stand a
chance again this guy magnus carlsen is
just playing too well in a couple years
ago won both the rapid and the blitz
championship the guy is not only amazing
at normal time limit for chess but blitz
and rapid as well so congratulations to
magnus carlsen we had eight competitors
in the champions showdown each of the
four winners in their head-to-head
battle get 60,000 the loser for each
head-to-head battle get 40,000 so not a
not a bad payday for Dingling
even when you lose a ton to go home with
$40,000 but great tournament got to see
a ton of chess when each of the heads at
battles was 30 games over four days
that's always exciting hopefully you
guys enjoyed this coverage and until
next time thanks for watching I'll see
you in the next video